we released a report that shows the FTC
is doing what they're doing name and
journalists by name asking what
interaction the company's having with
them the next day two of them testify
Democrats ask them who their sources are
and while they're testifying one of
those journalists the IRS is showing up
at their door that happened literally
again in a 48-hour time frame and yet
the Democrats say oh there's no
weaponization in government are you
kidding me
all right day three of three here in DC
and joining me today is the U.S
congressman representing Ohio's fourth
district Jim Jordan and a congressman
representing Florida's 19th District
Byron Donald's guys welcome back so
first off I I got to ask you about the
Sleep situation yeah we got a nice suit
here your sleeves were not rolled up you
just started rolling yeah I thought that
was your trademarks I guess sometimes
they're rolled up sometimes not but it's
good to be with you and Byron's always
looking good whether he's got a jacket
on or not listen this is the calm Jim
Jordan give them time give them time
when it's time to get into the issue
it's just gonna yeah and then it's gonna
happen I'll start asking about IRS
overreach and we'll see is that scary
man all right we'll get into that in a
second I thought it was interesting what
we were just talking about a second ago
you were mentioning how Ohio and South
Florida Southwest Florida there's a
connection there because of the
snowbirds and all that does that leave
you guys in an odd uh competition to
keep people in your own districts they
all like Byron they just come to my
district
it probably is a little bit of a tougher
self for the Ohioans right
literally some of our best supporters
guys who've been with me for a long time
uh spend a lot of their time in in in
Byron's District who were just out of
Naples had breakfast with a couple of
them a week ago Sunday so yeah it's it's
a great great part of the country as you
know because you got family down there
yeah yeah all right so let's get into
some of the some of the issues so uh
yesterday there was this hearing
basically about government overreach
what was the actual uh title of the
hearing
government abuse yeah something that we
we didn't have it in our committee but
it was probably in the in the oversight
committee um yeah there's I mean there's
there's all kinds of government
overreach we actually function from the
basic premise Dave that we think so many
of these agencies have been turned on
the very people the American people that
they're supposed to serve and you can
you can see it time and time again and
just remember what happened three weeks
ago three weeks ago Chuck Schumer goes
to the floor of the United States Senate
and tells Rupert Murdoch don't let Fox
telling a major Network don't let Fox
play the January 6 tapes the very next
day we we released a report which shows
the FTC is targeting a private company
asking that private company who are the
journalists you're talking to of Twitter
who the journalists you're talking to
names for journalists personally yep the
following day two of those four
journalists testify in front of our
committee
and while they're testifying the
Democrats ask them who are your sources
that all happens in 48 hours yeah that
was incredible I mean when you watch
some of this stuff and you're you're
somewhat new here when you watch some of
this stuff and you have Democrats
literally trying to get sources out of
journalists not knowing the basics about
technology and phones and how these tech
companies operate is it mind-blowing to
you that these people are even asking
some of the questions uh it is but wait
I gotta I gotta segue for a moment
notice the sleeves the sleeves came up
so notice that happens okay now back to
business yeah um it's it's it is
mind-boggling sometimes it's just flat
on insane yeah and once you start to
realize is the Democrats are always
looking to fill their narrative the
facts don't matter the issue does not
matter it's what's going to fill the
narrative these are the same people who
were basically trying to be the
Defenders of the media but now when a
story doesn't come out in their favor
they want sources they want to they want
the press to get rid of their own
journalistic Integrity none of that that
matters only thing that matters is
either perpetuating The Narrative or
protecting their narrative and that's
one of the saddest things that we see up
here on Capitol Hill when uh when
Schumer made that statement we played it
on my show and I said that he basically
made a mafia tactic that's what he did
because he basically said to Rupert hey
that's a very nice Fox News you got over
there it would be a shame if that thing
burned down
um and then the pressure's on yeah and
they basically hope you will destroy
your own business and we see that time
and time again when big government was
pressuring big Tech they were
threatening the 230 issue and other
things either do what we want take down
these tweets we think these tweets
violate your terms I mean think about
that the government's telling Twitter we
think these tweets we think these these
violate your terms of service when did
the government get that business and to
finish that never think about it so
Schumer says it we released the report
that shows the FTC is doing what they're
doing name and journalists by name
asking what interaction the company's
having with them the next day two of
them testify Democrats ask them who
their sources are and while they're
testifying one of those journalists the
IRS is showing up at their door yeah
that happened literally again in a
48-hour time frame and and yet the
Democrats say oh there's no
weaponization in government are you
kidding me so that was Matt taibi
yesterday as you were questioning him
IRS shows up at his door I take it this
stuff doesn't surprise anyone here at
this point like is that true no it
actually doesn't surprise anybody and so
that's when we start taking a closer
look at all the different agencies and
having a real scalpel well there are
people who are saying you know what
maybe we should reform these agencies or
maybe we need to cut Workforce the the
reason is is because you have there are
really good people in the agencies who
are doing the work that they were hired
to do yeah and then you have these
subgroups that exist where their entire
purpose is to play gotcha with the
weight of the federal government or to
or to suppress or to dissuade or to
diminish thought process idea Etc look
even with covid we saw it with the coven
narratives CDC going to Media companies
CDC going to social media companies
there are docs buying all the
commercials
Marty McCary Jay bhattacharya these guys
have far more experience and Technical
knowledge than some of them the folks at
the CDC and they were suppressed we have
the documentation it's all on record and
it was coming from elements of our
government and here's what I would say I
always say to the Democrats now if you
truly believe in protecting the soul of
America if you truly believe in Saving
democracy you can't allow elements of
our government to suppress speech of the
American people it cannot be allowed and
how does the response go on that they
want to protect the narrative yeah the
response is what are you talking about
yeah that's not true or that was
misinformation we can't let
misinformation out but who's going to be
the Arbiter who's going to be the judge
AOC Rashida Talib yeah Maxine Waters
Nancy Pelosi no for the record we tried
to get every single one of them in here
we got only one response and it was a no
that was from Regina so I'll give her at
least half I'll give her half credit for
responding but nobody else even
responded
um you've been fighting these fights
forever my sense yesterday having sat
with uh speaker McCarthy at the Capitol
is that Republicans are starting to wake
up even just the tone that you guys have
right now like there really does feel
like something might be turning here are
you hopeful for that I am and it's
interesting cause taibi wrote a piece
over the over the weekend where he
thinks that is happening in a broader
sense too not just Republicans I do
think Republicans get now look we've
seen so many agencies turned on the
American people
um and and the fundamental issue I do
think is what what Byron you were just
talking about Dave is is this attack on
the first amendment I mean I always tell
folks one of my one of my good friends
Dennis kucinich old school liberal yeah
yeah yeah who who truly believes in the
First Amendment he's a far writer Now
by their standards yeah but literally a
friend because he still Embraces the
First Amendment like the left used to
embrace but today's left is Byram is
just describing that they they don't
it's like if they use it to go after
their opponents we don't care about the
First Amendment we're going to go and
every Democrat this is a scary thing
almost every Democrat is an operative
you know Republicans that run in their
family they're volunteering at church in
their school and doing a little league
and all that but it seems like every
democrat's an operative including many
of these Democrats who are in in these
in these agencies so I do think this is
the Fundamentalist because if you don't
have a First Amendment you think about
it you're right to practice your faith
your right to petition your government
your right to assemble freedom of press
freedom of speech the most important one
is speech if you can't talk you can't
share your faith you can't you can't
practice your faith you can't petition
your member of Congress to redress your
grievances speech is the most important
and that's the one they're coming after
that's why we have to defend it so
speaking of speech you've had a couple
of nice moments in mainstream media
lately you had a blowout or uh whatever
how you could describe it in your own
words with with Joy Reed and uh it was
pretty indicative of I think everything
going on here with mainstream media
where they're acting as you know I think
she considers herself a journalist right
I mean if you asked her she'd probably
say something journalists but but she
clearly is an activist do you think she
was not prepared for that moment I mean
we clipped the entire thing and showed
it on the show and you just you just
calmly clearly
debunked her in real time live on MSNBC
well no actually I I thought she did
come in she wanted to come in hot and
she wanted to come in Rapid Fire you
know try to have me stumble or sign
sidestep or or have to restate something
and that's that's the clip so yeah kind
of going in that was my mindset it's
like okay they're gonna try to do
something just be prepared be calm and
then just take it step by step I think
going on her show or some of these other
shows what I think it helps my
colleagues and understand is you can go
into the lines then and do you know
ideological Warfare or maybe Warfare
might be too for too much for that but
you know you can have that dialogue you
can have that that back and forth and
actually come out the other side I've
had a lot of people come to me
afterwards they were like man Joey
didn't look good in that interview
I don't even say like I don't even put
it out there like look how I I owned her
yeah people say it and I just watch it
right right but at the core of it is
that you have to be factual and so a lot
of my guys on our side of the aisle I
tell my guys just be Solutions focused
just be focused on the solutions they're
gonna bring the energy and the fire to
it and you can go back at it with some
but if you always have in mind the the
end goals the solutions the Constitution
like Jim was talking the basic freedoms
freedom of speech First Amendment First
Amendment rights if you do that you can
win that argument because the the
biggest thing we're having to deal with
right now is that you have conservatives
we are the ones trying to frankly save
the soul of America we're the ones
trying to save everybody's
constitutional rights and Liberties it's
not the left and when you go in into
their shows into their wheelhouse and
you talk about that stuff it shows you
had more people in the middle of the
road in politics who basically like why
is Joy Reid lying yeah Social Security
is going insolving it's in nine years no
uh this parental uh education bill that
passed thankfully I was watching AOC
afterwards and she's talking about how
this is fascism basically uh the idea
and simply all it was was that parents
will just know what the kids are being
taught uh can one of you please go to
aoc's office and explain to her what
fascism is it's driving people crazy
well but there's also this fun remember
what Terry McCullough said a year and a
half ago in the gubernatorial race in
Virginia he said uh we don't think
parents should be telling government
what what their kids get in school and
you got to thank him for that yeah
but it's like you step back and you just
think about it for a second like okay so
some bureaucrat and Richmond who doesn't
even know the kid's name yeah cares more
about that child than a mom or dad like
it's just so stupid it's so ridiculous
and the good people of Virginia solved
for what it was and that's sort of the
basic here is like we actually believe
that moms and dads know what's after all
they know their kid's name for goodness
sake so bureaucrat and DC doesn't like
so the government that is well the
teachers are literally trying to rename
the kids that's part of this it's it's
so basic I actually have said this in
interviews
um it don't both I tell them don't vote
for anyone who's not for school choice
you've got Republicans pick the
Republicans for school choice that is so
fundamental yeah and that that's the
only way in the end we ultimately solve
and I wish we could have got more of
that in the bill but it's a good bill
that Embraces this fundamental idea that
moms and dads care more know more about
what's best for their son or daughter
well speaking of that we did it this
week in Florida we did it again again I
mean look I'm happy for the people of
Florida it's something that's been a a
long time coming
um my former speaker Richard Corcoran
back in the Florida legislature actually
stopped me from filing that bill not in
a bad way Richard understood because the
Supreme Court at the time before Rhonda
Sanchez became governor was a liberal
Supreme Court and he was like Byron if
you file that bill we're going to pass
it and if you pass it the Supreme Court
is going to strike it down because they
they're waiting for us to strike it down
so I want to make sure I set the record
straight for Richard and his
conservative Bona fides but this has
been a process a journey for Florida for
quite some time and I'm just glad that
my colleagues back in Florida and the
governor they just said we're doing it
and let's go because at the end of the
day you want to have a system of
Education where like Jim said the
parents are first in line if I get to
choose where my kids play basketball
where my kids go to after school who's
the actual doctor for my child what
clothes do you wear what shows do you
watch although you know today it's much
harder for parents to do that if I get
to choose all those things I don't get
to choose the school
that's that's that is that's
disrespectful of the position a parent
has in their child's life Florida
recognizes that I know Arizona
recognizes that now I think you'll say
it's Utah and there's going to be more
sense
that's right and more states are going
to follow do you think fundamentally the
issue for the Democrats on this is they
realize now if they lose the schools I
mean that's how they won this thing for
the last 40 years so they they sort of
feel like oh if we can't start these
kids on that path yeah when they're
literally five years old we'll be in
trouble yeah it's that coupled with just
public employee unions there's been the
power base in the Democrat Party for a
long time so I think it's those two
things meshed together uh is why you see
them so against school choice uh so
against empowering moms and dads to make
decisions for their kids and this this
crazy line about you know we had a
hearing last week that I thought went
well we're talking about the the parents
issuing what the doj and things have
done the Democrats were talking about
Republicans want to ban books and like
there's a big difference between book
Banning and age-appropriate literature
and that is the fundamentality and like
for them to argue it's just so stupid
we're not for Banning we want all we
that you're the one who want to like
restrict speech and bet we're for like
but but there's a difference between
what a second grader should be able to
see and what a 12th grader and what
someone in college it's like that's
common frequency he's so stupid I'm sure
you saw it when when Governor DeSantis
was giving the press conference about it
and he took out two of the books which
were clearly pornographic in nature and
the News had to cut the feed because it
can't show porn basically in the middle
of the day and that's the stuff that
they want there yeah look look I was
there I was on Ground Zero when we
pushed that bill through the through the
legislature when uh Rick Scott was
governor and we pushed that through and
at the time the Democrats in in the
state senate and state and the state
legislature were losing their minds you
can't do this you can't have taxpayers
and and parents look at Material they're
not they're not they don't have the
expertise to do this and our entire
statement was if taxpayers are paying
for it and the and the children of of
the children of these parents have to
look at it shouldn't they be able to
just comment view it and comment yeah do
that with your local school board engage
in civil discourse in an actual
Democratic process with your local
school board that's a good thing and
it's really good to see this now has
taken fire throughout the country
unfortunately a lot of kids had to be
subjected to material that they should
not have been uh subjected to but look
if there was one silver lining of covid
it's that parents got a chance to see
what was actually going on in these
classrooms and in these schools and
that's actually to the betterment of our
country are you guys doing any version
of this in Ohio now we've had we've had
good school choice in Ohio for for a
long time and and our Senate President
great guy good friend of mine
um is the most pro-school Choice guy you
can you can have so they're expanding
the school choice uh there but I think
that there's a there's a broader thing
that also came through with coven and
with this debate is I am so sick and
this is the less position now the
experts are make the decisions that's
not how it works in our constitutional
system it's the people who put their
name on a ballot get elected they make
the decisions because then if you don't
like it you can throw them out in two
years and that is a darn good thing
instead it's the fauces and the Collins
of the world who make all the decisions
and Dr fauci never once put his name on
a ballot went out and shook hands talked
to the people and got elected to
anything but frankly he ran the country
ran our lives for three stinking years
and everything else
yeah yeah are you feeling pretty good I
assume that when you come down or come
up here from Florida that everyone on
your side is going man in Florida like
you could feel it everywhere I've walked
around out here everyone Florida man
Florida Florida blueprint Florida I mean
what can I say you know you know we're
the leader in the nation right now yeah
look honestly Florida the Florida story
and I say it a lot in a lot of different
rooms
we're like obviously the hot thing going
today for obvious reasons great
leadership great Governor all that stuff
this has been a trajectory this has been
a pathway for 30 years in our state yeah
I think probably the last time we talked
I talked about it what you're seeing now
is what happens when you have consistent
conservative governance in an area you
see the opposite in California people
are leaving in droves crime is rampant
drugs are rampant it's crazy their their
legislature has gone off the rails and
so what happens businesses flee Capital
flees families are fleeing
kids aren't learning they're being stuck
between a rock and a hard hard place
because the teachers union is striking
because the custodial Union wants more
money that's what's happening in
California not Florida so if the rest of
the country wants to be you know a place
where people want to go start businesses
buy homes live their dreams and and do
everything else Florida is the blueprint
and frankly up here on Capitol Hill
Capitol Hill needs to start taking cues
from Florida yeah so that the entire
nation can Thrive this way yeah and that
is the whole point of that right that
really is it all right let's just knock
out a couple of the other things that
you guys working on this Tick Tock ban
uh I don't know if you saw this thread
with some of the real specifics of what
is in this bill this thing seems pretty
dangerous to me the bill actually in
terms of it's basically Patriot Act for
your phone now yeah how concerned are
you about that I I get no I haven't
looked at the details yet I know Senator
Holly may make a motion uh sometime
today or tomorrow and you were all
concerned about the China effort and
what's going on here but I do get
concerned that when you're trying to do
something good which which is what would
happen here winds up like restricting
Liberty and knowing where the left has
been over the last few years what
they're doing with the cancel culture
mob and everything else that does
concern me yeah have you checked into
what's going on with this bill I mean I
know that the idea basically of of going
after China spying on us that's one
thing but now it seems like it's a bill
basically designed for every bit of our
data to be used against us well look I
got real concerns yeah
we're still going through this stuff but
I got concerns initially when you talk
about Tick Tock specifically let's be
very clear the Chinese government is
taking a digital picture of the
decision-making process of young people
in America and people who use that app
in America that is exactly what they're
doing it's the same model that all
social media is largely built off of
that depending on what you look at you
kind of see what good what's good and
what's not and you can filter and do a
lot all that kind of stuff I don't trust
Chinese government at all so that's my
issues with Tick Tock yeah what we
shouldn't do is essentially redo right
Patriot Act on a larger scale it's a
Patriot Act by the way
um I get the premise obviously 911 but
what we've done as a result has not been
good for the country yeah I mean it
basically led to all of this and now
they're trying to do it on our phones
um let's talk about the the financial
stuff for just a moment the bank
bailouts and everything else uh do you
put all the blame on this on just that
Biden has in essence caused crazy
inflation and these Banks and they're
doing a bunch of risky things and this
was the obvious outcome well I think
that was the sort of the the main thing
is is the inflation the record inflation
which you know impacted the treasury to
what they had in these Banks and and
they they weren't liquid enough to to
meet the demand from certain depositors
um I think that's I think that's obvious
but it's all the spending that drove the
inflation I mean it's like literally
record spending and of course his budget
the president's budget we were at record
levels of spending and he increased it
even more with his proposed budget so
we've got to get a handle on that and
frankly I think we got to get in place
and I've pushing this the idea that when
we get to the end of the fiscal year we
we can't have this shutdown scenario so
what I want is a no shutdown act so that
okay we we want to spend less they want
to spend more the Democrats always when
they have the white outside oh we're
Republicans want to shut down the
government I want to say no no we won't
shut down the government but we'll spend
at some current level minus something
and then you can have a real debate
because if we don't we'll get into the
crazy stuff so that's what I want on the
debt ceiling at that that structural
change
um we'll see if we can get that you ever
think uh maybe a shutdown wouldn't be
the worst thing I mean they always frame
it as this is going to be the worst
thing ever but I'm kind of coming around
to the idea okay let them shut down for
a week or so let's see how how badly
we've done that several times
but I think in some ways now it's almost
like I think the fear is oh if we shut
down people are going to be like oh we
don't need these guys like I think
something has actually turned
psychologically in that maybe I think so
I mean look I remember even back you
know the beginning of this Congress
we're having all that all that stuff
going on yeah and it all worked out it's
actually been a very good thing yeah the
media was losing their minds oh my gosh
Congress hasn't convened it uh in day
two yeah what's going to happen sir and
I'm like
kids are going to go to school yeah I
was still able to get in there
the country will still function yeah
yeah we'll figure this out and move on I
think even if you get into the topic of
government shutdown the reality is
people still go to Disney even though
Disney's doing some silly things people
go to the beach you could have said Sea
World but we're talking about what
September trust me the NFL's gonna be
playing games yeah like life will
continue Washington's got to get its
house in order and now this is the part
that is critical we have to get out of
this it's a Jim's point this this
brinksmanship shutdown mentality yeah
where as a new guy on the hill it is
mind-boggling to me why we don't have
guys sitting in conference rooms all
over the hill going through spreadsheets
right now saying okay what about that
well this is that thing we can't really
spend like that we got to cut this here
you got we have all the time in the
world to do this except one thing there
is no political will to do it yeah
because if you have to sit down at a
table and go through budgets across from
your political opponents that's all good
you can actually get to a deal pretty
quickly is that particularly weird for
you because we're we're in a state
Florida where we have a surplus we don't
have a state income tax but everything's
working infrastructure projects 20-year
projects the governor told me are now
seven years because we have to build
faster because so many people are coming
like it's working there then you come
here and you're like guys can we do math
but also in most State legislatures you
have a mandatory budget that's
constitutional you have to pass a budget
it has to balance yeah you don't get to
deficit spend in the states here
oh we're oh we're short a couple hundred
billion oh okay throw it on the credit
card you can't do that at the state
level states have to balance their
budgets which is why in a lot of
respects people want to get balanced
budget amendments up here in Washington
I totally understand that but at the end
of the day it's the people you send if
you send members up here to Capitol Hill
who are not serious about the fiscal
future of the country you're going to
see more of this and that's the stuff
that we want to stop when you're talking
to Democrats about this is it that they
fundamentally just believe you actually
can print money forever that so that
that really is like that does yeah they
believe in that that monetary modern
monetary policy you're you're on the
phone I'm not on the French service
committee but that's what they believe
and it's it's frightening because
I mean we're seeing we're seeing what
happens now the inflation is just you
know 41 year 42-year high inflation rate
uh let me ask you guys one more which uh
obviously there's some momentum with the
Republicans right now clearly uh this
Trump DeSantis thing seems like it's
heating up you knew I was gonna have to
ask one way one way or another you had a
great answer for me last time on it
um you know I keep telling people I feel
like I'm gonna win either way because
either DeSantis remains my Governor
which will be just fine or potentially
he's president which would be great or
or if Trump's president that's great and
I still got the Santa's you know like
short of Biden being president again
there's a win in it I think for
Floridians but you guys might end up on
on slightly opposite sides of that thing
because because you're obviously a trump
guy in that regard and I know you like
President Trump of course but you're a
Floridian also how do you deal with that
internally when it when it gets hot
well I mean I'm for president Trump I I
I've said this many times I don't think
we've ever had a president who did more
what he said he would do
um I may have shared the story with him
before David but the mark Meadows and I
are in the White House probably I don't
know 2017 2018 and we're in the West
Wing there and we're in one of the rooms
I think it might have been Jared or
someone's room
big white board literally they they had
every promise written that President
Trump made to the American people in
2016 everyone you know cut taxes reduce
regulation Embassy in Jerusalem build
the wall to all of them and they were
just checking them off and that that is
I think that's how you're supposed to
govern so I'm a hundred percent for
president Trump and uh I want him to win
because I think he's got the toughness
to do it I like Governor sanus when we
formed the freedom caucus there were
nine of us he was one of the original
nine so he's a good man done a good job
in Florida but I'm for Trump
you want me to answer now no I mean look
at the end of the day the back and forth
is going to happen is politics
I've been through tough races Jim's been
through tough races you don't come up
here to Capitol Hill without going
through them
um you definitely aren't going to get to
the highest self in the office in the
land without going through it it's going
to be tough it's going to be bare
Knuckles at times that's just what it is
so I think for people in the
conservative base you got to understand
we've seen this before we've done this
dance before this will get worked out
too look if Donald Trump is President
phenomenal if Rhonda Sanchez is
President great
um the thing we got to do is we got to
clean house and count on DC DC's got to
get a house cleaning yeah and the one
thing I know about President Trump he's
committed to that work that work will
begin
gentlemen thank you brother you got work
to do that's right that's right get out
of here
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell